throwing up the deuces in tyreek hill's
face i think there was some confusion on
the broadcast a belief that that was
going to extend the drive once that
fourth down play happens
anything after that is yardage that gets
tacked on post play post and backed up
the buccaneers it didn't give
there it is there's the dude hey and you
know what if you're if you're tyree kill
and you're going to throw up the deuces
constantly that's what you get you're
setting yourself up for that someday
chris
like i i just i don't again i'm going to
go back to the refs here i don't i'm in
the dish to show you it's not about
favoritism towards anybody
it's the freaking super bowl like what
do they want
like guys not to show emotion i don't
know but it's not worth throwing flags
it's still taunting hey i i know i don't
think it i want
listen if taunting is you get in the
guy's face and bump them
and stand over them and straddle them
and do it that's taunting
okay then you're right then they need to
call taunting on tyree kill
but they didn't never call it on him i
know because it's cool
and he's running away from everybody so
it doesn't seem as personal
but it's just like to me stuff like that
just gotta go i don't care
stop the flashlight is running away from
us so we gotta get to our draft lasting
images from super bowl 55 what do you
got
i forgot about that um the lasting image
of super bowl 55 i mean i think the
number one thing that comes to my head
and that will always come to my head is
just brady hoisting the trophy in tampa
bay
with the you know the pirate ship behind
him i don't know how i could not get
that out of my brain
well that's just an amazing beat for
what he did
a team going there playing in the home
super bowl
winning it him holding up the trophy
pretty awesome in the
in the lures of of sports yeah i thought
you hated tom brady i know it happened
yup i dislike him for this segment only
by the way nobody threw the football
into the cannon porthole so
somebody actually bet three hundred
dollars on that uh damn
i hope you got i hope you got more of
that came from for me it's patrick
mahomes running for his life
and whether we want to use the snapshot
of him laying out like a shortstop
throwing the ball to first but
but it's patrick mahomes all night long
running for his life 497 yards
of running behind the line of scrimmage
before he threw the football
and again that's not on him the blocking
wasn't there
and the buccaneers pass rush was no
you're right it was uh that that's what
i toyed with too
it was one of those two right there i
went with the guy who won but
you're right i mean really i think when
i think about the moments on the field
you're probably that that's the moments
i think of i mean i'm always gonna think
of brady holding it up and like hey yeah
how about that
that's really cool but yeah when you
think about on the field it was almost
like
what do you think mike third fourth play
of the game where you went
whoa like are they are they gonna block
them at all today or like what's going
on here i mean it was pretty pretty wild
uh right from the get-go um
i think the next one and as you could
tell here i'm trying to come up with
these
on the fly uh i texted all of mine last
night on our chain just feel free to
well i'm gonna go with the weekend
at halftime we didn't like hit some of
that i'm gonna go with like guys
wearing bandages on their face with
lights on their hands the whole show
i thought it was pretty damn good you
know and especially
which like again is mind-blowing here
okay but
he paid seven million of his own money
to put on that show
i i i make it back well i know he will
i know he will but i mean the nfl
probably made that in what four seconds
of a commercial yesterday i'm just
amazed that he had to put his own money
either way i thought it was pretty cool
pretty well done without a full stadium
and everything like that uh i'll
remember the weekend and what he did
over time it has become obvious in the
music industry the value of that stage
so
yeah uh he'll he'll make it all back and
then some for me another one is
rob gronkowski running to the end zone
with the first touchdown of the game
that
because we hadn't seen a run like that
all year
and that was just kind of like that oh
bleep moment where hey the buccaneers
actually have a chance here
that just you know because i'm thinking
oh the chiefs are oh you know it could
get ugly they could blow him out oh god
it could be and then when he when he
scores that first touchdown
that's when i thought hey you know what
we're gonna have a football game tonight
yeah we didn't no
we didn't but but i thought at least the
buccaneers would be in it
and they were i i mean in it and you
know my thought
after that drive was like oh man that
looked a little too easy
it was a little scary you know it was it
was one of those things and you know
listen it was a weird night in the
household of the sims family i told you
my
my little boy loves tom brady i mean he
was rooting for him to death
over aaron rodgers but he wanted mahomes
to win
last night he wanted my homes but like
it wasn't as crushing to him because i
feel like he felt like he knew
he could see it anybody who watching
football you just went ah this team's
better
like maybe mahomes can make magic but
this team is better that's all there is
to be said
about the whole situation i think the
last thing uh i'll go
to maybe with the the the lasting image
is just the mauling of the offensive
line by the buccaneers and what are you
giggling at you weird nothing
all right you're over here texting
something and having fun
but uh the offensive line for the bucks
just the way
they just absolutely pushed around the
front four in the running game to have
150 rushing yards
you know with both basically the same
run play like we talked about and
the other thing too again i mean other
than the sack
i mean br they didn't get near brady
they they didn't even get close to brady
really
and that was phenomenal and that's
something i'll remember about you know
super bowl 55.
you know there's a bunch of different
ones that i know that i can say and i
don't want to keep going back to brady
um but that that moment with
with tyron matthews sticking his finger
in brady's face even if brady instigated
it
matthew it just it was this that was the
sign to me
did you see us after the game oh yeah
he's he never expected
that i've never really never seen that
side of it um
but but that to me was the moment that
the
chiefs were no longer that
that team with the aura right right the
aura shifted to the buccaneers once
brady broke matthew in that moment that
that to me that that's when i thought
oh bucks are going to win after that
play
after that that moment i'm thinking
that's when that's when i thought the
bucks were going to win well yeah and
that was what that one made it 21-6
right before that half right
it seemed like everything was against
tampa but even though we know what the
chiefs can do
even though we know what the chiefs can
do that's like yeah you felt like yeah
they were in another class of a football
team for this sunday no doubt
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports